welcome to the man of recaps this is the
book of boba fett in the mandalorian
season two we found out that boba fett
is alive he survived the sarlacc pit
yeah remember in return of the jedi he
was knocked in there and now we finally
get the scene of his escape he was
supposed to be slowly digested over a
thousand years but boba fett's not going
out like that and it's exactly what star
wars super fans have been imagining for
30 plus years oh yeah boba crawls
himself to freedom so boba fett helped
mando rescue baby yoda then came back to
jabba the hutt's palace where he killed
the guy who took over and with his new
partner and best friend master assassin
fenik shand he declared himself the new
crime boss of tatooine so the book of
boba fett starts off there what is being
a crime boss entail well mostly it's
walking around town looking tough he
rolls up to bars like what's up i'm in
charge now and collects his tribute
money now boba fett's trying to be a
good crime boss he wants to rule with
respect not fear like with jabba's old
bodyguards instead of killing them he
spares their lives and wins their
loyalty his partner fennechen though not
as forgiving whenever the choice comes
up her advice is normally kill him and
indeed being honorable has its drawbacks
because immediately someone's making a
move to assassinate him and boba fett's
got to show that he's the baddest dude
in town this assassin's not saying who
hired him so they drop him through
jabba's trap door that leads to his rank
orbit and that gets him talking real
quick although there's not actually a
rancor there anymore remember luke
skywalker killed it in return of the
jedi turns out the assassin was hired by
the mayor of mosespa who has this
assistant that is just absolutely so
sassy in such a polite way the mayor
himself is this real weird looking alien
who somehow convinces boba not to kill
him and boba's got bigger problems
because everyone wants his territory in
fact a couple of huts show up yeah they
are the twins they're like yo jabba was
our cousin and he left us tatooine in
his will and they've brought an awesome
enforcer with them it's this badass
black-haired wookie chrysanthemum that
night he sneaks in and rudely interrupts
boba fett's bath time for a slippery
bathroom fight but he's defeated by the
trapdoor they get a lot of use out of
that thing so once again boba spares his
life and recruits him to his team and
now the huts show up like oh our one
assassination plan didn't work that's
about as much effort as we were willing
to put into it plus they have some more
news apparently the mayor promised
tatooine to another crime syndicate and
they don't want to deal with it and
since they're not gonna use jabba's
palace they give boba fett the
replacement rancor they bought the
rancor trainer is of course danny trejo
and boba fett loves his new pet he's
like oh i'm gonna ride this thing so now
boba fett goes to see the mayor again
and after some more delicious sass this
majordomo tries to escape conveniently
boba fett had just recruited a london
street cyberpunk scooter gang and so
it's time for an epic chase through the
streets except apparently these bikes
top out at 20 miles an hour and this
whole sequence is just awkwardly slow
and bad but in the end they catch this
guy who reveals the mayor made a deal to
give tatooine to the pike syndicate and
boba fett knows these pikes in fact
every night during his healing bath we
get flashbacks to his time on the sands
of tatooine after escaping the sarlacc
pit the jaws found him took his armor
and left him for dead then it was the
sand people the tuskins who realized he
was alive at first he was their prisoner
but when goro from mortal kombat showed
up boba fett took him down and they were
like yo bro you're cool as hell you're
one of us now and so boba fett learned
the ways of the tuscans they gave him a
lizard which went up his nose and gave
him a hallucination trip where he found
a tree branch and made his own gaffy
stick but they were having trouble with
the train coming through their land so
boba fett went to a bar and beat up a
biker gang to take their speeders so
when the train came back the tuscans
were ready and it was a classic western
train heist and this train was owned by
the pike syndicate who was transporting
spice the biggest drug of the star wars
universe not to be confused with the
spice from dune which is also a very
valuable resource from a desert planet
boba's like hey this is tuscan land now
if you're coming through you've got to
pay the toll but the pikes did not like
that and they paid the biker gang to
massacre all of boba's new friends after
that as we know boba found an injured
venom chand and took her to the nearest
doctor who was less of a doctor and more
of a back alley robot mod guy which is
why she has a robot stomach now she
helped boba steal his old ship back so
he could go finish off that bike gang he
also went back to the sarlacc pit like
digest this oh sonic boomed that thing
so his near-death experience and his
time with the tuscans have made boba
fett rethink his life as a ruthless
bounty hunter he's like you know i'm
sick of working for scumbag crime lords
i think it's time for me to be the boss
and fenik shan's like hell yeah bro i'm
in so now we're finished with bath time
flashbacks boba fett's nice and squeaky
clean he goes to the other crime
families like let's unite against the
pikes but they're like nah this is a you
problem we'll remain neutral though so
to win this war they're gonna need help
but luckily boba fett knows a guy yes
it's the mandalorian he's back to his
old bounty hunting ways and these days
he's more boba fett than boba fett and
he's not here for just a cameo he takes
over two full episodes it's basically
the mandalorian season 2.5 he tracks
down his old mandalorian clan led by the
armorer who survived but it's just her
this one other dude now she's impressed
he has the legendary darksaber which
means he no longer needs his best garcia
spear he's like hey do you think he
could forge that into tiny little armor
for baby yoda but mando's actually
having trouble using the darksaber it's
weirdly heavy for him and she's like
you're fighting against the blade
whatever that means but then there's a
problem when she's like by the way you
ever take your helmet off and he's like
well i mean yeah there were extenuating
circumstances though it was a baby yoda
but in this mandalorian cult there are
no exceptions for tender moments and
mando is kicked out this is the way so
for now mando needs a new ship because
the razer crest was destroyed last
season and his mechanic friends found a
beauty for him it is an old naboo
starfighter like from star wars episode
one they have a fast and furious souping
up car montage and now mendo's got an
awesome chrome starfighter what this
thing lacks in trunk space it makes up
for in speed and in true fast and
furious style it's even got a nos button
now mando goes to visit his son at
boarding school at luke skywalker's
future jedi academy and yes we get to
see luke skywalker training little grogu
the little rascals up to his usual
tricks of trying to eat frogs and the
man himself luke skywalker's here with a
pretty good looking virtual face
replacement but a fake voice that still
feels kinda stiff but mando doesn't get
to see him he stopped by the other jedi
so katano she's like hey man i know you
love him but to be a jedi he's got to
leave his old life behind you come to
visit him he's just gonna make that
harder and it's heart-wrenching but manu
agrees it's for the best and decides to
leave but we the viewers don't leave in
fact we get like a full 20 minutes of
baby yoda jedi training his first lesson
is to learn to jump which oh my god are
you kidding it's so cute and pretty soon
wow this guy's hopping around yeah mando
can sell that stroller but when luke
hears about mando's visit he's like all
right little groku i'm gonna give you a
choice you can have this super cute best
gar steel chain mail and go be a
mandalorian with your papa or you can
stay here and be a jedi with yoda's old
lightsaber which you're gonna have to
grow into i guess but unfortunately you
can't have both cause that would be just
way too cool so finally back to the
show's main character boba fett mando's
here but they still need more numbers so
amanda goes to his other friend on
tatooine cobb vance the marshall but his
folks just defend their town why should
they get involved with the gang war but
amanda's like hey if we don't stop the
pikes now they're going to take over the
whole planet so he says he'll think
about it but five seconds after mando
leaves a mysterious stranger coming in
out of the desert and if you've watched
the clone wars animated series this
silhouette is immediately recognizable
it is the baddest of the bad bounty
hunters cad bane he's been hired by the
pikes and it's an old school western
standoff where oh shoots the marshall
and so it's time for the grand finale
with an all-out gang war the first big
problem is the other crime lords who
promised to stay neutral they cut a deal
with the pikes and ambush them godfather
style taken out to all boba's friends at
the same time so now boba fett and mando
are surrounded way outnumbered and it's
time for their last stand at the okay
corral yes mando and boba fett teaming
up two versus an army busting out their
full arsenal of weapons yes but no
matter how cool there are they're way
outnumbered and are gonna go down but
luckily the folks from freetown show up
here to avenge their marshall plus the
wookie chrysanthemum also survived oh
yeah he's awesome oh and uh the shiny
vespa gang survived too but now we got a
bigger problem because the pikes bring
in a couple of epic war droids they're
fully shielded you can't hurt these
things as mentors are retreating he gets
a ride from his mechanic friend who came
here to find him because she has a baby
hoda yes little grogu made his choice he
wants to be with his papa mando
unfortunately at the moment they're in
mortal danger and things look bleak but
wait what's this it's the rancor with
boba fett riding it alright this thing
is a beast and working together he and
mando take this thing out yes the rancor
goes on a rampage and very quickly the
battle is won but now cad bane shows up
and he ain't afraid to know rancor knows
this thing's afraid of fire so it's time
for the final showdown between cadbane
and bo buffett as bounty hunters these
two go way back in fact in the clone
wars like they hung out when bobo was a
kid but cad bane's quicker on the draw
oh he's gonna take boba out but boba
fett oh trips him up with the tuscan
gaffy stick and a final fight goal stabs
him i highly doubt they brought this
character into live action just to kill
him immediately so maybe we'll see him
again but now there's another problem
without boba fett here the rancor is out
of control but it's little grogu who
steps in there proving he's the apex
predator the rancor is kinda just a big
frog and he uses the force to calm this
thing down and now together they have a
little nappy time now fenik shand was
notably missing from this whole finale
she bailed early because she tracked
down where the pike leader and the other
crime bosses were hiding and al goes
full punisher assassin mode her boss
boba's not here to show mercy she takes
them all out and so the day is saved and
boba fett has earned his spot as the top
crime boss of tatooine although he shuts
down the spice trade and really isn't
doing any crime so he's more like the
new mayor and more good news and then
after the credit scene the marshall cobb
banth is in boba's magic healing bathtub
with the robot doctor so looks like
he'll survive with maybe new robot parts
so boba fett is ready to roll tatooine
with honor while mando and baby yoda are
reunited and that's where book of boba
fett comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member